let's get a little bit more into the
domestic issues and uh i want to say i'm
just i'm sorry it's coming to this for
people who are watching you might not
want your kids to hear this stuff this
stuff's dark stuff
but this is the president's son
the daily mail reports
naked hunter biden filmed himself
smoking crack drinking hard seltzer
and um
you could do himself you could just say
that you can you can read it yourself at
home yeah while floating inside a
sensory deprivation tank one month after
convincing dad joe to wire him twenty
thousand dollars for his detox program
the first family the son of the
president
these videos are coming out because the
laptop got released and the stuff we're
learning about this family is is dark
it's bad stuff
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
and my in my personal opinion i think
joe biden was abusive towards his kids
because you don't turn out like hunter
biden unless you had bad parents doing
something
bad family
you you take a look at how hunter biden
turned out
and then you have to ask yourself about
the leadership capabilities of joe biden
and then you look at the country and you
start to put it together right
so i don't i don't know uh you know what
you guys what your thoughts are on all
this stuff more more of this is going to
keep coming out i think it absolutely is
indicative of who the democrats are
willing to elect regardless of their
moral character and of the leadership
capabilities of the man himself that is
the point right there we knew we knew
there were problems this is not news to
a lot of people i was following this
before the 2020 election
i knew a lot of this before the 2020
election and the fact that the media
kept that the corporate media bosses
kept that from making its way to the
people so they could make an educated
vote and decision when they when they
went to vote
uh look at twitter but there were a lot
of democrats who probably knew that and
and said they didn't like trump so they
so wanted to get president trump out
that they were willing to vote for
someone like that here's you know the
reality is
trump has done bad stuff you know he
he's he's said mean things he called
stormy dale's horse face he called
didn't he call someone a fat pig or
something like that rosie o'donnell
rosie o'donnell only rosie o'donnell i
don't remember that from the debate only
rosie o'donnell but here's here's the
issue the overall majority of the bad
things they claimed trump did they made
up
they they they fabricated it
so with
i just don't want to i don't want to get
distracted by donald trump when we're
talking about the biden family has its
own thing that's pretty horrific when
you when you start to dig it open agreed
agreed my point is just we had to win an
election in 2020 and it was between
trump it was between biden and what the
biden voters are going to say is you
expected me to vote for trump yeah he
called white supremacists very fine
people which he never wasn't really
exactly and so they believed the lies
about trump they believe the lies about
people like kyle rittenhouse i tweeted
the kyle rittenhouse thing was put me up
put me over the edge to vote for trump
because i saw how they're trying to
destroy this guy and we needed to push
back and stop this
and that was you and trump pinned it to
his profile on twitter and that was used
by many on the left to accuse me of
being wrong or being right wing or
whatever or far right
but i was correct when in fact you
actually had the courage to stand up and
say the truth about a young man who was
being persecuted
and and they wanted to tear you apart
and destroy you and when that happened
to you you probably went oh i think i
know a little bit what it must be like
to be president trump right now i'm
feeling that myself because i'm already
attacked right now
and you're getting 150th of it uh
exactly i talked to president trump
regularly and i said i know i'm getting
the trump treatment right now and you
know he
you said he's done some bad things i
don't think he has i disagree with you
on that i think he's done some amazing
things his family i know them they're
incredible people
but the media has been tearing them
apart relentlessly
since 2015 2016.
and some people have just bought into
that because they still believe the
media and what i want to tell people
after working in it for 30 years is turn
it off do not believe it they've got an
agenda and you just can't believe it i
mean honestly i'm getting better
information here at tim cast you're
putting i'm listening to you before this
show and you're very thoughtful on what
you're putting out and making sure
things are accurate we're not all
perfect sometimes you make a mistake
i'm watching you and after working 30
years in tv and in journalism i'm
thinking
this is more journalism than what i was
seeing in journalism the last at least
five six years i will say to clarify my
point on trump i think trump is great i
think
uh i can understand why people don't
like his character i've i've i tell
these stories i've talked to regular
people so they don't like the way he
talks but i know a lot of people do like
the way he talks and the way i saw it
was we needed someone to fight back
especially with the media lying about
people like kyle rittenhouse but no no
one's perfect we needed a
a brash
new yorker to come in remember he beat
back 18 other
republicans many of them rhinos
establishment swamp creatures we needed
a tough brash new yorker who told it
like it was we couldn't get some
mealy mouth person to do that and thank
god he came in at that point but there
are things that trump uh
here's what i'm saying
what joe biden is
i view him as corrupt
i view trump as having done bad things
as either mistakes or making bad
decisions people are allowed to make
mistakes people are allowed to make bad
decisions you criticize them for it and
say do better there's things about
donald trump that i personally don't
like but for the most part i think he's
a good guy i think he was actually a
really great president
um i don't like some of his foreign
policy decisions but i overwhelmingly
like his foreign policy
so commando raid
potentially killed a little girl an
american citizen that's what we've heard
i would like to see an inquiry into that
getting our troops out of the middle
east was the first president in my
lifetime who not only did not start a
war but was actually ending wars so for
that
here's what here's what i want to be
careful of if you come out you're just
like trump is the best he's so good then
people are people who have questions
about things he's done they they shut
they closed down
but i also don't want to play this game
where it's like oh trump was so awful
when the reality is oh yeah it wasn't
perfect he did some things that i think
were questionable wrong or just bad but
joe biden
is
unthinkable yeah 100 i think yeah what
you're saying is you're trying to say
hey you know trump wasn't perfect we're
all humans but joe biden is not just
imperfect he is corrupt malicious he's
delicious and you look at his family we
know trump's got attacked and his
children got attacked
joe biden raised this family and if you
look at his daughter's diary i mean
this is crossing the line in a serious
way where police should have been
involved possibly even arrests
involved joe biden there's such
insidious
stuff in that family yeah and it's not
just the reasons that people dislike
either of them but they're such an
organic
appeal to trump whereas the support for
biden is all
reluctant support
because they hated trump i don't see
anybody enthusiastic about biden never
and i didn't see it before 2020. so
brazenly
just screwing the american people it's
almost like their hatred for president
trump is so
overwhelming and eating them up that
they're willing to sacrifice our country
our constitution our freedoms
okay we got them out i don't know if
it's actually that they hate trump i
don't know if they're smart enough to
actually hate the man
so i think it may have been austin
peterson lydia hurried me if i'm wrong
who was talking about a friend of theirs
but we had a guest on saying uh their
friend believed they were like a liberal
democrat that trump called white
nationalists very fine people
and so he said just here read the
transcript and the person started
reading it and then like paused and then
scrolled back and started reading it
again and then just froze got up and
left the room unable to process the fact
that that donald trump never said white
nationals were very fine people i don't
remember who that was that was awesome
peterson it was also peterson yeah i
remember that and it was a huge story
and i remember hearing his entire
remarks and going i don't remember him
saying that then the media would
perpetuate it over and over and i even
went back
a couple of times and listened to what
president trump said to am i hearing
something wrong because everyone's
saying
he said this and i remember hearing that
looking back at it a couple times just
to make sure i didn't mishear it so i
don't i don't think they hate trump i
mean they do hate him but what i mean to
say is
it's not real because they don't know
they didn't investigate they didn't
bother to i think what actually
motivates these people is fitting in so
you walk around new york and everyone
just says oh yeah i hate trump too and
so they go okay that's their identity
fitting in social is more important
right than than in being inquisitive and
finding out the truth for me i do you
think people living in more conservative
areas do the same thing
i've uh
well i'll tell you because i live in a
red state
i think we're a little bit we're a lot
more who cares what they think about us
we want the truth
now not to say we don't have people in
in arizona who are like you just
described they're more the peer pressure
gets to them that's why when i see to be
honest a young conservative and we have
a lot of them involved in our campaign
and they'll say oh my gosh i'm so
inspired by you and i think oh i'm a
middle-aged woman of course i'm going to
be
bossy and and tell it like it is this is
what middle-aged women do right
but i say no i'm i'm inspired by you
when there's a young person 18 20 years
old 22 who's pushing back against that
peer pressure is that what you still
call it peer pressure is that an
outdated word they're pushing back
against their social pressure social
media
and speaking the truth um
that is actually very courageous well
let's let's talk about the founding
fathers because before the show we had
some interesting uh data points lydia do
you sell that data about the founding
fathers yeah do you want to read it sure
well we pulled it up and it looks like
the founding fathers were i want to say
james monroe was 18 years old 18.
these are the designers of the
democratic declaration of independence
18. 18 years old yep two of them were 20
years old the oldest one mentioned here
was no thomas jefferson was 33. wow we
have 20 20
five who were the questions madison was
twenty five i believe so i saw that the
responses to that
it's a tweet right listen
to the story i saw a tweet that was
listing those ages and the responses
were like well it's because the life
expectancy back then was like 45 so an
18 year old was the same as a 35 year
old that's not true like true
yeah the reason the average life
expectancy was so low was because of
infant mortality but if you survived
infancy you were expected to live 20 70
or 80 years old we were talking i think
it was ian and i were saying and i would
take a nine or ten year old from that
era because they were so competent they
could
farm they could hunt they could do
anything they were so
resourceful i would trade them probably
for you know the average
person in america today who is not
able to to have those survival skills
that they had somebody's stoned on
aspartame
crazy fake children we're not we're not
practically skilled or
emotionally
sophisticated like developed either well
you talked about what's happening with
farmers and maybe there could be a food
shortage at some point back then they
wouldn't worry about that because they
were growing their own food you know
regarding this climate change fear that
they're telling farmers not to grow
fruit food i find this sad because
there's a lot of evidence that we can
withdraw the carbon from the atmosphere
i don't know if you've been following or
with no farmers what's that with more
farming with more farming i don't know
plants absorb carbon that's one way to
do it but you can actually deposit the
carbon dioxide onto like palladium or
other metals and then withdraw the graft
the carbon from it and get graphene just
building materials but they don't know
it's like the the politicians either
don't know
i assume they don't know it's ignorance
because if they knew
there would be another discussion like
it's the most valuable resource on earth
this carbon and if we could just get it
back you can get it right out of the
smoke stack too well so uh do you uh do
do you know where the mass of a tree
comes from i would the roots
no we're just breathing seriously i
don't know you guys know where the bar a
tree grows
right there's mass accumulating where
does that matter come from co2 that's
right because it's from the air it
sucks out kind of what we consider
pollution what we consider pollution is
its life
the building blocks of a tree come from
the air it takes the carbon it builds
like how ours comes from the food that
we eat that's their food is the carbon
dioxide well it's also water well and
they emit oxygen as well right we kind
of are they they take the carbon dioxide
and rip the carbon off and spit the
oxygen back out so when you have farmers
being told not to farm it's like uh
those crops actually absorb carbon from
the atmosphere why would you why would
you not want that now i can understand
concerns about nitrogen is what they're
they're saying i'm not sort of talking
about carbon but we want more plants to
be growing so why wouldn't just be like
hey plant a bunch of trees like you know
allocate a certain amount of time plant
trees and these places anyway look i'm
not going to pretend to be an
environmental expert i'm sure whatever i
said made no sense some scientist is
probably like tim you're wrong for these
reasons like government but don't you
think that that's not really going to
know anything either exactly the same
position yeah what are we saying well i
think we all want a healthy environment
we want to have clean air clean water
but it's gotten to the point where it's
being pushed so much that it's
destroying our economy pushing companies
out oh you're gonna pollute too much too
much co2 and the company finally says
you know we'll just move it to china or
india
and and then they take all those jobs
away they destroy all those families
they destroy a local economy
and you know talk about an animal in in
peril the human being and but yet the
environmentalists are okay with that
that company setting up a manufacturing
or factory in another country and
polluting there there's actually
in india are terrible about pollution
right and so so are you do you care
about the world the globe or don't you
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there